la unión europea se muestra optimista
frente a la posibilidad de reanudar el
acuerdo nuclear con irán el jefe de
exteriores del bloque apuntó a avances
sustanciales esta semana esto a pesar de
que la unión europea y las partes
implicadas están a la espera de la
respuesta de eeuu a una propuesta de
acuerdo lanzada por bruselas
eeuu no ha contestado formalmente
todavía
pero estamos esperando su respuesta
y espero que esa respuesta permita que
acabar
la negociación
lo espero
pero no lo sé no puedo asegurar el mundo
sería un lugar mucho más seguro si
pudiésemos
volver a hacer funcionar este acuerdo la
propuesta del bloque fue planteada tras
16 meses de conversaciones irán envíos o
contrapropuesta a la semana pasada
murray la calificó de razonable podemos
hablar de que esta ronda de
conversaciones será fructífera sólo
cuando los europeos anuncio en que han
recibido unas respuestas de los
estadounidenses la unión europea ha
servido de intermediario en las
negociaciones indirectas entre
washington y teherán este último se ha
negado a un diálogo directo desde que en
2018 el expresidente donald trump retiró
unilateralmente a eeuu del pacto una
retoma del acuerdo detendría el programa
nuclear iraní que según expertos estaría
portas de lograr la bomba atómica a la
vez supondría el levantamiento de las
sanciones sobre la economía del país
persa y quitaría un gran peso sobre sus
ciudadanos a nivel internacional un
nuevo pacto permitiría el flujo de
petróleo iraní en los mercados lo que
aliviaría los precios de los
combustibles en la economía global